formé en cuisine je suis fort mis en
compte a fait pas mal d'expérience dans
diverses divers types de restauration
ce qui fait qu amendé j'avais un bagage
qui fait que
même si je suis une femme en fait j'ai
démontré que j'avais les capacités et
que j'avais travaillé pour pour
justement contrer ce côté peut-être où
on fait un petit peu moins confiance à
une femme quand même à la base faesch
que ses tresses et la mère quoi passer
la maman donc
et que du coup
une cuisine dans les restaurants
pourquoi pas pourquoi ça étoffe d'avoir
une femme alors qu'à la base
voilà c'est là où nous a mis à jour par
intrigue où on nous a cantonné et
et voilà je sais qu'il ya un petit
paradoxe je trouve je pense qu'on est
plus
tasty soumises aux tests et
et qu'on doit faire
plus ses preuves par rapport à un homme
je pense qu'en règle générale
après deux mois dans mon expérience
personnelle c'est vrai que j'ai eu la
chance de
ne pas avoir trop ce cas mais il ya
toujours la petite le départ on sent
quand même qu'on est un petit peu plus
sous observation va dire peut-être qu'il
ya des taches les tâches les moins va
peut-être pas forcé donner forcément
donné les tâches les plus délicates où
les plus importantes à une femme parce
qu'il ya une femme et un homme sur le
même poste
voilà peut-être peut-être aller plus sur
l'homme sur le parler en fait enfin sur
la relation entre collègues
je pense et la relation entre
une personne qui va avoir le poste juste
au dessus et qui va
qui va pas forcément être très
respectueux enfin moi respectueux que
par rapport à une qui peut être moins
respectueux par rapport à une femme
après c'est plus ça va être des plus des
petites réflexions ou des petits voilà
des petites blagues
un petit peu machiste ou des choses
comme ça alors après je pense que des
fois c'est
si manière qu'ils ont pour se défendre
aussi ou pour ce parce que voilà quand
ils voient contient coup et coiffée
d'affaires votre grille mais voilà
pouvons pas c'est que c'est tellement
courant et c'est une manière de parler
qui est courante dans le métier et
peut-être qu'en fait c'est
c'est pas qu'on s'habitue mais on se
rend pas forcément compte des fois de la
portée des mots en fait de l'importance
des mots et en fonction de la personne
qu'on a devant soi ça peut
l'impact peut être complètement
différente à prendre aux filles que bah
ouais là c'est pas c'est pas normal non
plus qu'on vous parle comme ça ou c'est
pas normal ça pour pas hésité à parler
s'il ya ça ouais je pense que c'est
important
[Musique]